cette photographie s'intitule tattoo 2
elle a été réalisée en 1999 par
turgetier un artiste chinois
contemporain
cette photo a été présentée alors
peut-être en 2002 lors de l'exposition
matière à penser c'est ce que j'appelle
une photographie corporelle nous sommes
donc en présence d'une métaphore
visuelle qui nous éclaire sur la
relation continue et sans limite entre
le corps et la photo entre ce qui est
donné à voir le corps de l'artiste et sa
pensée
c'est une véritable icône aujourd'hui
représente
à elle seule l'art contemporain chinois
c'est une oeuvre particulièrement
réussie
on y voit le corps de l'artiste
réduit à la planéité et ramener aux deux
dimensions de la photographie parce
cet énorme caractère calligraphie rouge
qui lui traverse le corps et qui
l'aplatit un peu contre le mur
il semble un peu scotché par cette
calligraphie dans le sens et non ne pas
c'est l'interdiction en chinois et ça se
prononce bout nous sommes là face à une
forte critique de la société chinoise
laquelle un effet uniformisant sur ses
membres c'est en quelque sorte une
société qui semble nier le corps de
l'individu au profit du corps social
et cette référence au tatouage d'où le
titre tattoo qui signale l'exclusion
renforce le propos et la pensée de
l'artiste c'est donc une image qui est
visuellement très forte qui est devenue
une icône aujourd'hui et que
l'artothèque nous sommes vraiment fiers
de de la posséder dans nos collections